good morrow to thee citizen it's a time
of year when Americans count our
blessings and give thanks and I'm
thankful for so many things Capaldi is
the new doctor there's going to be
another evil dead movie with bruce
campbell and the new Game of Thrones
book is coming out someday maybe and
I'll just come right out and say I'm
glad that futurama got cancelled again
that's right I said it I was a super fan
watched every episode repeatedly
deciphered the alien languages both of
them tared up whenever I heard the name
see more but I'm glad it's now going off
the air see the last few episodes were
fantastic a second cancellation means it
goes out on a high note and won't suffer
a slow decline like the simpsons which
should have remembered to file a do not
resuscitate order with the doctors
before going to the hospital I for one
believe that we in the geek American
community should be more inclined to
celebrate when a show ends before its
time see ever since be Joe Trimble
spearheaded a letter-writing campaign to
save the original Star Trek nerds have
been known for their grassroots
campaigns to rescue shows on the verge
of cancellation if not for me Joe
there'd be no Tholian web that Captain
Kirk is no longer alive
no all our yesterdays no Enterprise in
today is think to bleed used the Vulcan
death grip but there'd also be no spots
brain oh come on bones what's the
mystery his brain is gone on a
journalist Fox brain and that's my point
off times less is more my favorite
series is the prisoner which called it
quits after a scant 17 episodes doo doo
doo doo doo oh look a bit with a
super-secret-agent what is he doing he's
resigning but why only he knows but
during that brief run it managed to
explore every angle of its premise
three-member so evil twin episode
body-swapping episode spy spoof episode
even a Wild West episode before wrapping
everything up with a satisfyingly trippy
ending maybe it's a good thing then
Firefly came to an end after one skimpy
season what if subsequent seasons
diminished our good feelings about the
show like the like heroes see I prefer
two seasons of twin peaks with an
agonizing lack of closure to however
many seasons have lost their were before
for the dark times which is why i'm
starting a letter-writing campaign to
get NBC to cancel community again who's
with me but come on you'll be thankful
next year ah stop it not the face search
your heart you know it to be true what
much love show would you like to see get
the ax let me know in the comments